[Musique]
cette rafale de rayons gamma est la dernière chose
que l'humanité verra avant que nous ne
disparaissions, nous
regardons essentiellement le canon d'une
arme à feu. Je connais votre travail, mais si
je vous disais que j'avais un plan, c'est le  seule
chose assez puissante pour arrêter ce qui
arrive montrez-moi à quel point vous êtes vraiment fort,
c'est inutile, c'est ceci avec l'
annonceur de la police, on nous dit maintenant que
le nom de l'homme est Joseph Steadman ce que
les rues
maintenant vous voyez comment cela fonctionne Cho
plus vous êtes en colère  plus tu déverrouilles pour
voir jusqu'où nous pouvons